their eyes it's always the eyes always
right eyes yeah as always go first those
are the windows to the soul and once you
take that away they just become this
empty husk of a human being right saying
they don't have souls
the video game characters Jake hey
everyone welcome back to potato mode the
game where we take the most beautiful
games we know and turn them into mush my
name is Joey I am joined here by Jake
Decker what's up and we're gonna be
playing some Far Cry 5 so we're gonna be
diving into it kind of trying to see the
game on its highest settings and slowly
descend into the pits of graphical hell
we're gonna reduce it all the way down
to as far as it can go in the game and
then we'll take a couple extra steps to
make a look even worse after that if you
guys have any suggestions for other
games that you'd like to see potato
moded is that I think potato do modded
yeah leaving them in the comments below
we will get to them in a future episode
but for now we're gonna be playing some
Far Cry 5 and my goodness look at this
dang gorgeous where we headed I don't
know I just kind of want to romp in this
field for a little bit bump in the field
all right so right now we have the game
set up at 1080p everything on Ultra and
it looks fabulous but that's not what
this show is about no it's not the show
is about taking this beautiful setting
right here and turning it into something
a little bit more mushy so we Archie
maybe starchy that's the word was
looking for hundra quality we're just
gonna go all the way down to the bottom
the lowest for everything for resolution
scaling we're gonna bring it down to
half so you have half the amount pixels
but we're not gonna be at 1080 we're
gonna be at 720 that's the lowest the
game will let us go to keep that 16 by 9
all right there we go this is a game
send us one Freddy 720p I mean you got
like like it's still detail on
everything like that but it's just the
the flickering yeah everything is kind
of still there except these were once
nice and Christmas and now they're all
just kind of it's just one jumble of
pixels all together
yeah the shadows aren't looking looking
too hot here take out those tires No
okay now settings are too low for tires
to blow out our oh that's a nice truck
deliver to me yes you just you just like
to punch everything yeah kind of a
releasing some anger here Jake this is
not gonna work what's not you know it's
driving this whole thing this whole
thing these settings these graphics
we're gonna have to do a little bit of
surgery here all right so right here is
the Nvidia profile inspector and this is
where all the magic is going to happen
we're gonna change these from zero to
1.5 each this is how Joey likes to cook
his potatoes exactly and then we'll
change the multi sampling to a a mode
replay mode all so we're gonna hit apply
changes and then we'll jump back into
the game
whoa all right we got some um weird
stuff going on with the floors here it
looks like the floor was is looks
interlaced hey do you think you can help
me out here look at they all have a glow
around him too
this still doesn't look too bad doesn't
look too bad we might have to go further
I might have you might have to do a
little bit more we're now into
open-heart potato surgery all right
we're back in here and 1.5 wasn't enough
I like doing 120 okay or 240 I believe
is the the highest it will go I've
memorized the hex value of it which is 0
X 0 0 0 0 0 0 F 0 be very careful with
doing this in case you want your game to
look good but if you're like me and
enjoy breaking stuff just in general
then by all means
go ahead and do this break stuff but
just be careful all right there we go
this is the far cry remember those lines
are [ __ ] I believe those are like
they're like lions they're like venetian
blind they're supposed to be shadows
maybe I don't know oh hello doggy their
eyes it's always the eyes they're always
right eyes yeah it's always go first
those are the windows to the soul and
once you take that away they just become
this empty husk of a human being right
saying they don't have souls I mean the
video game characters Jake oh it's even
on the map that's nasty it's like Google
Maps when it hasn't fully loaded yet
once again got a punch the door first
and make sure it's sturdy Oh again - any
any cars that don't sturdy doors block
bullets for you what are those - all
right those they look like some sort of
vegetation and waiting for like Mario to
jump from one to the next or just rise
up out of it yeah well you know remember
how the Far Cry arcade has other Ubisoft
properties oh yeah we were saying what
if they put Mario and rabbits in there
oh yes this is this is basically what
you're gonna get look at the fire
actually it's kind of cool oh my car
don't well I didn't somehow survive that
this looks like it's that steam game
called jalopy or you like know your
reminds me of that and you know enviro
bear no it's like this iOS game where
you play basically a bear trying to
drive a truck through the forest oh yes
so crappy yeah kind of like this it's
got a little bit of a charm to it right
yeah you know it's it's something well
that lens flare let me see that again
a beautiful boxed up just for our
enjoyment so
what is my goal here it's something you
know if we can't get a quest from him
whoa we'll make our own quest okay let's
try to find our own things to do is that
what you're supposed to do with this
game
find your own fun we could still get
some testy fest testicles we'll just
coat the the not correct way there's no
wrong way to harvest a testicle wow this
is looking a little minecraft desk yeah
seriously you know the cow is just like
blows it off oh there we go
you took them all by a bear oh my god oh
wow oh my gosh I just want to watch this
right here
yeah oh I don't have the flamethrower
anymore that's okay throwing anything
are you throwing rocks it oh no you
throw a grenade what does it have ol the
wolf got it seriously
Oh what happened here why is it so dusty
Oh you completed a mission don't know
which one but I did it should take the
tractor up there behind you perfect oh
shoot you know what's gonna happen what
you triggered a story missions they're
gonna try to hit you with bliss and
you'll load into a story mission so we
could actually see a cutscene no no
drowning by this guy like I said just an
empty husk I know this is the whole
point they're cleansing our souls right
getting rid of the eyeballs yeah cuz we
don't we don't know we look like right
now for all what for all we know we
could be a normal human being and then
after they do this this is when we look
like them yeah I think you've nailed it
Joey this is this is far cry 5 the the
the hidden the trading backstory the
most immersive way to play far crack
behind what is our sin anyway I don't
know is it gluttony too many potatoes
what all right well I think that about
does it for this episode of potato mode
if you guys have a game that you'd like
to see potato did we say potato two
potato fide potato fide make sure to
leave it in the comments below and we'll
try to get to it sometime later in the
future but yeah that was far cry 5 in
potato mode thank you guys so much for
watching and we'll see you in the next
episode
if your follower buddy how's it going
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
I'd like to ask you the same question
yeah you need to shoot down birds and
get a key what's up you gotta talk to
him oh that's one punchy face
you still don't get it f prompt though
okay no that's the Hopa makeup sorry
about that